the eyes to the right 202 the nose to
the left
432 in the past few days Theresa May has
made history but not for good reasons
she suffered the biggest defeat of any
modern government in Parliament there
was a majority of 230 votes against her
brexit plan Britain is in a real pickle
now when it comes to brexit there are
now only about 10 weeks left until March
the 29th which is when the country is
due to fall out of the EU Deal or No
Deal and at the moment there is no deal
the Prime Minister thought that she had
negotiated a good withdrawal agreement
with the EU but it has to go through
Parliament before it can be legitimized
and Parliament is indicated very clearly
that it's having none of this Teresa
made herself said we're now in uncharted
territory and that's about right
Britain's got a reputation for being a
sensible moderate kind of place we've
had a unbroken democracy here for a very
long time and yet now we find ourselves
in this real crisis and the reason for
that is that we've got a long history
here of representative democracy in
which people elect MPs who take
decisions on their behalf but the brexit
referendum of 2016 injected a rarer kind
of direct democracy in which the people
gave a specific instruction to the
government and what's happening now is
that those two different kinds of
democracy are kind of jamming up against
each other
you've got the instruction of the people
in the referendum that says that leave
has to happen but then you've got their
elected representatives who they elected
only in 2017 saying actually the terms
of the withdrawal are not acceptable to
their constituents and the trouble is
that both of these views have legitimacy
on how you resolve these competing types
of democracy is not at all clear that's
why Britain is in such a mess
many people thought after the referendum
in 2016 that because it was such a
closed result it might be possible to
find some kind of compromise to go for a
so-called soft brexit but it hasn't
worked that way at all if anything since
the referendum the two groups that
remain group and the lead group have
actually grown further apart part of
this is the fault of tourism a after the
referendum she could have reached out to
the party she could have reached out to
remain as to try to forge a kind of
compromise but she didn't do that
instead from the very beginning she went
for a hard form of braixen she drew it
up in secret with a few advisers and
given the very split nature of her party
and of parliament and of the country
this has actually been exactly the wrong
approach and that's what's resulted in
this unprecedented defeat the most
important thing for Britain to do now is
stop the clock and extend the two-year
article 15 negotiating period after
doing that she can try and negotiate
with other parties in Parliament and
she's indicated that she wants to try to
do that but the Labour opposition so far
has said that it's unwilling to
negotiate with her until she takes the
option of No Deal off the table and she
doesn't seem keen to do that it seems
now that possibly the only way to
resolve this crisis could be to put the
question back to the people and to have
a second vote what we have at the moment
is this absurd situation where their
elected representatives think that the
deal is a bad one but some of them feel
they ought to vote for anyway on the
basis that it may be what voters want
but we can't know that for sure people
voted narrowly to leave but the brexit
deal that's now on the table is really
quite different to what they were
offered in 2016
now voters might want this anyway they
might decide that these trade-offs are
worth it but they might not and the only
way to find out is to ask them